Having this information, being able to
know this information up front, right when,
at the beginning of your pregnancy early on, is that something that's important
to you in the process? Was that something you were happy to know
about, or do you wish you kind of, couldn't find out maybe until later?
>> I'm going to skirt that a little bit and I'm going to
talk about it in third person because it's such a personal choice.
>> Sure. I'm going to tell you that I have
friends that have fallen into all of these different categories.
I have one friend that buried three babies in
five years because they kept coming up with that
25% chance. I have one friend who has two
average size children. So they came up with that
25, the other 25% twice. and I have friends
that have said, oh, we'll never get pregnant, because
we don't want a dwarf child. We went through
so much ourselves, we would never want that for our,
our child. I have friends that say, I'm scared
to death of having an average sized child, which I
don't understand because I teach high school. You know,
that is not a big deal, and I have these
great friends in LA, whose son, as I just
told you, is 6 foot 4. so, you know, this,
this choice that we are now given, or the
access to this technology, maybe. Is, is very, very powerful.
I'm going to tell you a quick story. We, we had a regional conference in Los
Angeles about a year ago. Three women all in their 20s all kind
of grew up together by default. I mean not necessarily in the same town.
But because they're been Little People of
America members all of their lives. All pregnant.
Now, they all have had the testing. One of them did not want to have the
testing, for religious reasons. But far along
into the pregnancy decided, I don't want to go
through baby showers, I don't want to decorate
a nursery, unless, there's a reason to. So
it's not going to change anything about the
pregnancy. I'm going to go through the pregnancy but
I need to know. And so she knew she
was carrying a double dominant. And there she was with
a smile on her face with the other two
women. One of whom had already buried a double dominant
and was on her second try and knew that,
that one, I believe was going to be average size. And
then the third young woman knew that she was having
a heterozygous dwarf and there they were all happy and
talking, and I just, the strength that the girl had that knew that she had
a double dominant inside of her, was just amazing. It gets a little bit
more sad, so, the baby lived a few hours. They waited the three months that they
were told to wait. They got pregnant again. And again, had a double dominant.
And, and kept it. And that's their own choice, and
aren't we lucky in this country that we have choices.
>> Right. Knowing everything you know now as yourself and with the
current technologies even maybe thinking about
the possible advances in technologies that
we'll have in the future in your lifetime or even possibly, you
know, beyond that, would you change, would you choose to be different?
And sort of as a variation of that, you know if you could choose this for your
children how, would you?
>> I think, like my, my first answer is we call
it the magic pill. You know if you had been able
to take the magic pill to not be a dwarf. And
I think my response to that magic pill would have been
different depending on what decade of my life you were
asking about. I would most likely have taken that magic pill
in middle school and probably high school. prior to that
I don't think I really cared. I was just a kid.
I've never faced out right discrimination in my
job at Hunts. So I think that magic
pill may have been between middle and high
school, but after that you kind of get awfully
comfortable in your skin. Is do you think it's harder to be born disabled or to
become disabled later on in your life. And
the people that are really on it and thinking
have actually, it blows my mind when they
give me the answer that I'm looking for.
Which is this. Most definitely it's harder to
become disabled because something has been taken away from
you. With the exception perhaps of being blind
or deaf. Because if you become blind later
in life you, you know what things look
like. So you can reference that when you can
no longer see them. If you become deaf later in life, you've learned how to
talk. You can talk. And I just, I just want to kiss em when they give me
that answer. because they truly are thinking about it. And so when I think about
our soldiers that come home disabled I really
feel for them. Especially soldiers who were big,
strong. Buff guys and gals and they no longer are. And
that, and I feel for them. And I'm so proud of them when they turn that around
and they become the wounded warriors or
the wheelchair rugby teams or something that
they're putting that, energy and they're channeling
it into a different realm, a positive realm.
>> What,
what do you say to people who
have their own struggles and particularly with your
perspective, how would you tell them to, to
what's the best way to handle their struggle?
>> This is probably trademarked, but it does get better.
[LAUGH]
It's a catchy phrase.